TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for The Developer Show.
Today we're at the
Chrome Dev Summit
at the Yerba Buena
Center for the Arts
in San Francisco, California.
Now, all the sessions are
recorded and available online,
but let's say you just
want the highlights.
Well, that's why I'm here, to
give you the Chrome Dev Summit
top five.
Number one on our list is speed.
Now, this isn't so much a new
feature as an increasing focus
we should all share.
Ben Galbraith, who leads product
for the Chrome Platform Team,
cited HDTV Archive
and said that sites
are using an average of
eight times more JavaScript
since 2011.
He and Dion Almaer, who leads
product for the developer
ecosystem, later discussed
performance budgets,
which are a great practice
for ensuring our performance
stays on track while
still enhancing our sites.
There is a lot of
great supporting
data from Wayfair and
Pinterest, so this is definitely
a thing to try.
Also helpful for
speed is, of course,
the Page Speed
Insights Tool, which
is now powered by Lighthouse
and has real world
data from Chrome UX and more.
Super useful.
Next up at number
two, the Squoosh.app.
This is demo that uses
WebAssembly to power the image
codecs and service
workers to work offline,
and all the code is
available on GitHub.
Seriously, the link is just
at the bottom of the page.
It's also a really useful app
for image compression that
allows you to dive pretty
deep into the advanced options
for image compressors.
The keynote took a quick
look under the hood
of this app with
Chrome DevTools to see
how the UI stays
fluid by keeping
most of the heavy lifting
off the main thread.
It was really cool.
Number three, Web.dev.
Web.dev is a new
learning website
that includes principles,
guides, tutorials,
and plenty of sample code.
There's also a couple
of killer features.
First, Lighthouse is integrated.
And it lets you track the scores
of your websites over time,
as well as giving
instructions on how
to resolve specific issues.
Now second, Glitch is embedded
so you can remix and test
example code right in the site.
Number four had to
be Project VisBug.
This experimental
Chrome extension
is meant to change how
developers and designers
interact with web pages
by providing a point,
click, and tinker interface,
which is actually really cool.
In the keynote demo,
UX engineer Adam Argyle
was able to use guides,
edit positioning and color,
edit text, and
even drag and drop
image replacements
all without pulling up
a code window or Dom Viewer.
Oh, and of course,
it's open source, too.
Number five, Frameworks.
The Day Two keynote
did a great job
of explaining just how important
web frameworks have become,
as well as conceptualizing
them within the web
stack next to web primitives,
built-in modules, and web
components.
And they talked
about how Chrome is
investing in them by including
web frameworks in the Chrome
Intent to Implement
Process, funding
for improving performance
best practices in Frameworks,
and increased collaboration
with Frameworks
from the Chrome team.
OK, one more highlight.
Number six, Jake Archibald
dropping Chrome's birthday
cake.
And that's it, your
Chrome Dev Summit Top 6.
For more announcements
and updates,
click on the links in
the description below.
And on your way there, take
a moment to share this video
with your friends.
They'll thank you for it.
And we'll thank you
by doing more of them.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show,
and I'll see you
at the next summit.